hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so what we're gonna do in this
video is we're going to talk about
related rates and specifically a problem
that comes up a lot in your calculus
class which is the ladder which is
sliding down the wall of a building so
let's get right into this problem you
can go ahead and pause the video if you
want to try and you know solve it on
your own and then double check with what
we do here or if you just want to follow
along as we do it just go ahead and do
that so here what it tells us is a
ladder 17 feet long is leaning against a
house the base of the ladder is pulled
away from the wall at a rate of 3 feet
per second okay and then there's three
questions so question number one says
how fast is the ladder moving down the
wall when its base is 15 feet from the
wall okay so first thing I want to do on
these related rate problems is draw a
diagram so we can see what we're dealing
with so I'm just gonna sketch it right
over here okay and I'm gonna draw it on
a coordinate axis system sometimes this
is helpful not not in every problem you
need to do it this way but for this
problem I'm gonna draw it like this so
basically here's the 17 foot ladder ok
17 feet here's the base over here I'm
just going to call that axe okay so
that's the base of the ladder it's
leaning against the wall here this is
the y-axis so we'll call this dimension
Y and you can see it's a right triangle
okay so step number one is our diagram
step number two is to you know state
what we know and also you want to state
what you want to find okay so what do we
know here well basically what we know is
that you know they're pulling it this
direction at three feet per second so
that's the change in the X direction so
dxdt equals three feet per second so
I'll just write it as three and what we
want to find is how fast is the ladder
moving down the wall so that's this
direction so what we want to do is we
want to find dy DT okay when x equals
fifteen feet okay so now we want to
write an equation that relates all of
these variables okay with what we want
to find and with what we know
the best equation here that relates
these three is the good old Pythagorean
theorem right so we have here is we have
x squared plus y squared equals 17
squared a squared plus b squared equals
c squared right now the next step is we
want to do implicit differentiation okay
with respect to time with respect to T
for time so what we're gonna do is we're
going to take the derivative x squared
which is 2x dx/dt
ok so that's the chain rule plus
derivative of Y squared which is 2y dy
DT we're doing the chain rule because
we're not taking the derivative with
respect to Y we're taking the derivative
with respect to T and then the
derivative of a constant is always going
to be zero okay perfect now let's
substitute in what we know and solve for
what we want to find so we know DX DT is
3 okay we know that X is 15 okay because
they're saying at that moment when X is
15 its 15 feet from the wall plus y is
let's see we're gonna be now let's see
let's draw a diagram here so you can see
it this is 15 this is 17 if we do the
Pythagorean theorem at this particular
point when this is 15 feet Y will be 8
so that's going to be 8 and then dy DT
is what we're solving for equals 0 so we
substitute it everything we know we just
have to solve for dy DT so let's go
ahead and do that this is 30 times 3 is
90 if we subtract it to the other side
we get negative 90 this is 16 if we
divide both sides by 16 we get dy DT
equals negative 19 negative 90 over 16
which reduces down to negative 45 over 8
feet per second now you might notice
this is negative and what that tells us
is that this is going down so the ladder
is sliding like this and it's going down
so that's why the value is negative okay
so that's part a let's look at Part B
now Part B says find the rate at which
the area of the triangle form is
changing when the base is 15 feet from
the wall so they're saying you know
what's the rate that the area of that
triangle is changing
when this is actually like this at
fifteen okay instead of like this okay
so what's the formula for area of this
triangle well area equals base times
height times 1/2 right but in this case
it's going to be one half x times y all
right so you're with me so far so what
we're gonna do is we're going to take
the derivative okay with respect to time
so this is da DT equals one half and I'm
just going to pull the one half out and
we're gonna do the product rule because
x and y are multiplied together so
that's going to be x times three little
Y which is just one dy DT Plus now I'm
going to reverse it I'm going to leave Y
alone I'm going to take the derivative
of X derivative X is one but we have to
do the chain rule
okay so DX DT and then this whole thing
is multiplied by one half that's the
constant multiple rule okay so now all
we have to do is we're solving for da DT
let's substitute in what we know so
we've got 1/2 X we know is fifteen DX DT
is 3 y is we figured out why was eight
and DX DT I'm sorry I made a mistake dy
DT we actually said was negative forty
five over eight and DX DT that's this
direction here is three okay so now if
we multiply all this together we're
going to get the change in the area with
respect to time okay so all you have to
do is multiply all that together now
what you'll notice is this guy actually
comes out to a negative value which
means that the area when you get to this
point here is actually getting smaller
it's decreasing so that's what the
negative tells you if it was positive
then it would be increasing okay Part C
last part on this problem is find the
rate at which the angle now okay between
the ladder and the ground is changing
when the base of the ladder is again
fifteen feet from the wall so they're
saying you know how is this angle right
here theta changing when X is 15 so what
we're trying to solve for in this
problem is D theta DT that's what we
want to find D theta DT when x equals 15
so what's an equation it relates this
angle
and you know in this triangle well the
ladder is always fixed at 17 feet so and
we're interested in we're interested in
this angle here when X is 15 so let's go
ahead and use the cosine we're gonna say
the cosine of theta okay
equals adjacent over hypotenuse so
that's x over 17 all right so now what
we're going to do is we're going to take
the derivative with respect to time so
we're gonna do our implicit
differentiation derivative of cosine is
negative sine theta D theta DT okay and
then this is really--like 117th that's a
constant so it's 117 times the
derivative of X which is 1 DX DT okay
good so now let's substitute in what we
know so the sine of theta okay at this
point in time sine is going to be
opposite over hypotenuse so that's 8 17
times this negative here D theta DT is
what we're solving for the change in the
angle with respect to time and we know
that DX DT is 3 okay so now all we have
to do is multiply by the reciprocal of
negative 8 17 so we're just gonna
multiply by negative 17 8 that way those
cancel negative 17 eighths and if we
simplify this down you can see the 17 s
are cancelling and we get negative 3/8
radians per second so this is calculated
in radians again notice that the angle
is negative which just means that it's
decreasing okay as you're pulling that
ladder away from the wall and that angle
is going to be you know decreasing at
the rate of three eighths of a Radian
per second so I hope this video helped
you understand how to work with related
rates a little bit better especially
this problem about you know the ladder
I'm gonna have a link to another video
another related rate problem it's a cone
type problem so we can dig into that
deeper but subscribe to the channel
check out some of my past videos and I
look forward to helping you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon